so welcome everybody um
so today
what i wanted to do today is to go over
a reinforcement learning environment uh
that is uh
it was released by google research
it's called google research football
is a soccer environment um
i like this environment for a number of
reasons um
i think one of the the best things of
this environment is that is a
multi-agent environment
but you can actually customize it you
can customize the back end uh so that uh
the the
uh
the uh
the reinforcement learning portion of it
the agent actually perceives everything
as a single agent so it's a good
introduction to the to a variety of uh
types of environments uh and i think
it's a a
pretty good one to talk about today
so you probably know that i um
i pushed a docker
image
in a
github repository so if you haven't
gotten that go ahead and get it because
um we're going to be going over that
code and you know it's much better if
you actually pull it
and follow along
so let me let me show you real quick
the
where to get the code
um so all right so the the repository is
in this address
uh so you can see here my
uh so this is my github github account
uh so g football
dash our live dash intro
so go ahead and pull that repository and
then try to follow these instructions
over here i think the most important
instruction there is that you want to
um
you want to do the docker pull of the
image
because if you don't do that i mean it
may take you a a
some time
so you don't want to be waiting on that
uh
too much
so go ahead and do that right now
it's probably going to take a little
while um to go over the entire thing
so but um all right let me see so go
ahead and try to pull that image
um when you pull that image try to open
the image like so um you can see here
so this is for instance i i cloned the
repository here
um and then so from the top from the
root of that project i'm going to run an
nvidia
docker command such as this one
it's slightly different you can see it
on the left here this is the one that
i'm currently running and i just want to
let you know what's in here so here
first you clone the repo that's pretty
obvious right so clone depth one this
just basically tells me don't give me
the whole history i just wanted the most
recent code so you know sometimes people
checking stuff and this one is a brand
new uh project so i don't think you you
have any problem with that
this the first thing to do is to pull
that image uh once you have that image
now you're going to run that image
like so
this port over here is going to be the
jupyter notebook port
this port over here is going to be the
tensorboard port
and this port over here is going to be
the rlib well
more accurately is going to be the ray
port
and then this is going to basically
map the directory notebooks
from your host machine
uh into your um docker container okay
and actually this um i believe this
command actually laha gave me this
command if i remember correctly
for the window side so just do that the
same thing the only difference is going
to be the cd as opposed to pwd
and just a you know disclaimer that i'm
using
nvidia docker which basically
passes through or allows docker
containers to use
um
um
the
basically the gpu so the all the
information that all of the
just the gpu i guess that's that's the
straightforward way to
explain that one so that what you're
going to be able to do is then train if
you have a gpu you're going to be able
to train uh inside of docker container
using the gpus that your server your
workstation has
so other than that uh these are the the
urls that you're gonna have have to open
um i already did
i have them right here so let me let me
kill this um
terminal window so this is the right the
ray dashboard
this is the tensorboard and i think i
removed i clear the stuff yeah okay so
this is the
thing i was testing the code and this is
the jupyter notebook okay
and
uh um of the things that you're going to
have to do is once you open the docker
the um the jupyter notebook it's going
to ask you for a password
do rldm and you know sorry for
for the password i read somewhere that
is important to do that and
so i did that's it all right and then
here we are with the co with the code
all right so didn't know about the
nvidia docker yes
absolutely anyone else have tried this
on windows
i think laha
actually has done it on windows so
um
and and i think lahai is actually
watching the stream so if you if you if
you know uh
yes i did yeah i think you gave me the
those commands so
all right cool
all right so
one quick thing
uh obviously
you know this stream is to let you know
also that deep
rock indeed reinforcement learning the
book that i wrote um
almost
500 pages well actually 450 around that
uh has been released um
i do like the paperback although
honestly you don't see the the the
amount of time that is spent tweaking
the figures and making you know putting
the colors and stuff like that well i i
have somebody help me of course but um i
actually paid that on my own because i
wanted to have a really high quality
book now the printed version is not
color so you know
i think the two sides see i recommend
you you basically you know try to enjoy
the two sides and i think you're gonna
like it so it's released
um
it's going to be available on amazon um
november the 10th i think uh so next
week
um
and i'm pretty excited i think um i
think this book does a really good job
at introducing the concepts okay so
reinforcement learning
is is this you know machine learning
technique that lots of folks are
um
you know using lots of really big
companies such as google deep mind or
open ai
and other companies to many many other
companies are using uh to
basically automatically learn
behaviors okay
um
i think the major challenge with uh
reinforcement learning in general
is that um
for a newcomer it's really hard to get
in because there there are so many
there are so many kind of uh
i'm gonna call it lingo um there's there
are so many words that if you don't know
what they mean you just lost you try to
you start you try to read a paper
right and start reading from the top and
you're gonna get thrown a lot of words
and you're gonna probably
understand ten percent of the paper
uh so what this book does
is a a ramping up of all those concepts
all the way from the very beginning from
scratch all the way through
so that um
so that when you finish this book my
goal and i think i did a good job at
that my goal is that you finish the book
front to back
the entire book
and then you're able to grab a research
paper and you go
ah
ah
understand all of that stuff
and i think i accomplished that i i
really um i'm very satisfied i wish i
i could spend more time on the advanced
topics such as you know multi-agent or
uh model-based and you know
you know cool topics that
um are important but then i thought you
know this this
field is so challenging that if i don't
start with the basics then you know most
people are not going to get the advanced
stuff and i think that the advanced
stuff
i think after you finish this book
you're gonna be able to get the advanced
stuff a little bit better as opposed to
me just writing about this this the
advanced stuff and just plopping code
and saying like here have fun this is
how you do it this is the code but not
being able to actually explain it in a
way that you can understand it uh so the
rocking part
is uh i think is accomplished in this
book so i recommend that that's one
thing uh before we begin the second
thing that i wanted to mention is
so i suggest that you follow me on
twitter
my
handle is m-i-m-o-r-a-l-e-a
in case that you
don't have it there i'm gonna type it
very quickly
so just look
oh well i guess yeah this is my handle
and you can see that's my handle
basically everywhere so you know even
stark overflow whatever it is uh but i
recommend you follow follow me on
twitter as you can see i pimped out my
my desk my area
and i'm planning to start recording some
videos and posting on youtube so i'm
going to announce
those videos
um
i'm obviously going to be using twitter
to announce those things but i'm
planning to kind of go through some of
these well i guess a variety of videos
but one of them is try to explain the
same concepts that i explained in a book
but in a in a video format and uh
perhaps uh have sessions in which i
answer questions and hopefully you know
i found a way to bring you guys into the
live stream so that the questions can be
asked uh live i i like the live
interaction a lot so i think it adds to
the stream
um and also you know q a sessions and
also like uh deep dives into into the
papers i also have interviews with um
you know
i work at georgia tech as well so i i
have
a couple of jobs and then i was writing
the book uh but one of my jobs is uh a
an instructional associate at georgia
tech very happy with with that role
and one of the things that i do there is
i bring a special guest and then i do a
an office hours with them and an
interview basically um and um actually
in a couple of weeks i'm gonna have a
new guest uh i'll be announcing that
um
in in on twitter uh uh short as well in
a in a week or so
uh but um if you go to my youtube
channel and i i call that channel right
now the agent whisperer uh it's even
hard for me to pronounce i don't know
why i put that name but anyway just go
look it up um
uh you already can see interviews with
you know reach sutton uh with leslie
kabuen with michael mann with uh joshua
kim i mean there's there's a lot of uh
sessions there already uh but in
addition to that i'm gonna be you know
i'm gonna be continue to do that uh but
i'm also gonna be uh adding uh
instructional videos and you know deep
dives into papers and things like that
so make sure to go over there subscribe
to the youtube channel you know do the
little
bell or whatever so that when i start
releasing the content which i plan to
release by december you can actually
start getting that content uh i mean
this version is good it's live uh but uh
when i do those those i'm probably just
gonna edit and try to give you content
that is more uh you know boom here it is
i'm gonna explain to you mark of
decision processes and nothing else boom
and so on so
so that that that is uh
that is a well the second is the twitter
the third is a youtube channel so uh
with that out of the way
um
let's get started with this um all right
so let's see how do i do this thing uh
here boom
okay yeah
so
reinforcement learning is oh well let me
see if there are any questions or
anything
uh brady went through the 50 oh 50 pages
awesome explains the main comes very
very outstanding that's your youtube
yeah it's hard to pronounce but is the
agent whisper rare gosh
i talk i asked my wife like what what
nate should i put and uh yeah
she's like that and i i don't know how
to pronounce that thing well anyway
but i'll learn no problem
[Laughter]
all right so
okay back to this
uh reinforcement learning is a pretty
cool feel okay
now unlike
um
i'm gonna say uh let's see most people
are are
used to
um like the traditional fields of
supervised learning right in which you
have a data and then you
basically process the data and do some
things with it
and then you go ahead and um
you know train a model
on that particular data and
reinforcement learning you know some
people think that the data is perhaps
the environment and uh the supervision
is the reward
and it seems to be you know one way but
uh
i don't i don't really like it how when
people do that kind of stuff um i wanna
so
if you get to work in reinforcement
learning get a job in reinforcement
learning the majority online unless you
are you know you're going through a phd
and you're going to be a research
scientist
as a research scientist let me actually
get a little whiteboard or blackboard
whatever this is yes
so a research scientist would actually
work on getting the agents
part of of the reinforcement learning
pipeline you know down
um
but in reality there are many components
there that i want to show you so one
will be
that the agent right so i'm going to
call here the agent
another thing in reinforcement learning
and you're probably familiar hopefully
you are
environment
okay that's that's the second layer but
there's another layer over here and in
fact there might be actually two layers
but i'm not gonna complicate it i'm just
gonna stop right here i'm gonna say this
one is a simulator
or
you know i can also call this the real
world right
and usually
or a lot of the work
if you're if you're an engineer i don't
know what your background is it's going
to be here
it's going to be in the environment
because a research scientist is going to
work here
and those guys
that are really good at math
and um at research um are pretty good at
that
um if you're an engineer you're going to
fall into this place
into the the um
this guy over here
um or of course or the simulator portion
over here but usually the simulator
um
already exists so there's a lot of work
usually done in in the integration of
you know hey i have a simulator
that uh can make you know that airplanes
can fly and you know it's a flight
simulator obviously uh right or um
or a simulator such as oh atari atari is
a good example right so the the atari
environment is actually a stella
it's called the it's an emulator
emulator so that's actually just like an
atari emulator that you can play in the
computer
and then the environment is basically
making that uh grabbing information from
that emulator and passing it through the
to the agent
right so in reality the agent doesn't
talk to the to the simulation the agent
actually talks to the environment
okay so i think that distinction is uh
often overlooked
and is something that is
um important to to be aware of okay so
the one thing is
or one of the things um is that
there are often lots of simulators out
there and you can actually go ahead and
look it up i mean i'm not even kidding
you uh if you look for gym
uh environments usually just go you know
like this
uh gym
environment
and then you know search for
you know flight simulator
you're gonna find
reinforcement learning
environments
that
are
that have a simulator on the back end
okay
in the particular case of the project
that we're going to be working on today
that is a
basically you can see in in that paper
is like a little you know looks like a
like a game like a video game right
so i mean who has played soccer uh video
games in the past that's what it is
right
so this guy
is actually the backend this is what we
call the simulator this is not the
environment and you can create from a
simulator like this one you
can create many different environments
okay
the kind of cool thing that google
research did by releasing this
is that they
um you know they hook up this simulator
with with soccer and then gave you the
ability to create many different
environments that you can think of okay
the environment
and let me go back into the whiteboard
thing
um you know
usually when uh so the communication
here is like this guy
oh that's not what i intended to do
let's see that okay so this guy talks to
this guy
this guy talks to this guy
then this guy to this guy this guy to
this guy so usually it's like that the
communication goes like that one
information goes from one way from one
place to another well from the agent to
the environment there's an action being
passed in
and the action can be
you know can be discrete can be
continuous can be a vector
so you can pass an action that is you
know a zero
uh or you know zero to ten
that is a single integer right it's a
single value that can you know carry
different values can be from zero to ten
uh you can also have a a vector right
that you know 0.314
um
comma whatever
whatever right so
the action can be anything that you want
it can be a combination of course in and
you know if you you can obviously make
one of those uh a kind of kind of flow
with a threshold to make it a discrete
value so if there is
let's say that you know in your in your
simulator right here let's say that you
have a
uh an airplane a fighter a jet that
fires a missile
um if the fire action is not continuous
you don't need to you know it's you know
0.1 what is that it's a button right you
push the button and the thing
goes out so you can you can train the
agent with a threshold right so that you
say hey you know one once this value is
uh greater than 0.9 then that's it
all right but
you know without getting into those
specifics
the actions come into the environment
and something happens in the environment
there's some processing going on in the
environment okay something goes
usually that processing means you're
going to apply actions to the simulator
depending on the information that is in
here right the environment uh some
people
say like oh the environment is kind of
like an adversary to
the agent uh no no don't think about it
like that it's not a and it's not like
the agent against the environment and
the agent uh tries to
get points and the environment tries to
not let the agent get points that's not
uh the way reinforcement learning is
although of course you can create such
an environment that's not
a good
definition a general general definition
of the environment
so
if you develop this portion over here
you can do whatever you want with it
okay
um
you know you get that information of the
action you go out and process
you know try to what we call step the
simulation right you step apply the
actions then step the simulation then
query the simulation to get the state so
this basically in here what comes out of
the the simulation
we can call a state obviously simulation
can have
partially observable
information but you know most of the
time what we get from the simulation is
the state
then the environment process that state
and then output something to the agent
it returns to the agent an observation
observation
which is basically a filtered version of
the state or a processed version of the
state or it could be equal to the state
uh and you know i mentioned this in my
book but um you know
lots of folk folks actually mix those
two and it's not bad intention is you
know it's just the way it is uh but just
know that uh when somebody says
observation they mean that there may
there is likely that there is uh some
information that
uh that is uh partially observable is
not fully observable the agent doesn't
know the true location of the airplane
the the agent knows a sensor
uh view of the location of the
airplane which contains noise and and
all that stuff
so
you get an observation you get the other
thing you get is a reward
and this you know this is a little
challenging but uh we'll talk about that
a little bit um in a minute
um
and then you know usually not mentioned
because
um
they're used in a in a different way
the dawn and the info
stuff
now what i'm describing here is what
open
ai came up with so when when you hear
open ai
gym
what people are referring to is two
things twofold
one is a collection of packages that
bring a lot of different environments
and i mean like a lot of different
environments such as
you know
all these implementation basically okay
so that is one thing the second thing
that they
did the good contribution
is
a an interface and the interface is
basically a few functions actually it's
just you know the step function that
takes in an action
and returns these guys
okay the second thing is a reset
function
which
doesn't take anything but it returns an
observation
and then so the reset is going to become
like the entry point of an episode so if
you think about it as an episode is when
you we can call it a trial right when
the the agent is going to start trying
something from zero it's like the
beginning of the of a game of chess
that's that's you reset the environment
and it goes back to that initial
position
and
then you start stepping through the
environment passing actions to the end
so in reality the very first thing that
the agent gets is not not a reward it's
a an initial state is the state so this
observation is what the agent uh gets uh
to begin with okay and then the other
thing that uh you know it's a render
function
rand
there
function um
and you know a close and so on so a
couple other kind of you know helper
functions for the environment but they
came up with this interface
and uh lots of folks now can
implement this interface
um basically and uh the awesome thing is
that you can now leverage
right lots of implementations of agents
because if you have that interface here
if you create all that is in here
you can plug in any agent basically
whatsoever
that you need that you want
okay
uh so let's see seems to have an issue
it's working on windows 10.
let's see uh repo that i've tried this
not this one uh the repo should be very
similar so
you know uh
look in the mail yesterday excellent
outstanding super happy for that um
yeah so if um
the repos of gdrl and this one are
almost identical but i added some you
know i added the uh the soccer
environment so that you guys can test it
out and i also added our libs so that
you can guys train you guys can uh train
agents using against this environment so
i think that is a good contribution so
that so that you guys don't have to mess
with that and you can see the helper
functions that i created i mean i'll be
honest with you guys it's not perfect i
worked on it today
so um but um but it should actually work
and kind of help you
uh you know go forward i know this this
stream may take a little longer than
than i
you know i thought it's not just an hour
i think it's gonna go a little bit over
but you know it gets recorded so if you
guys you know have to go to bed or
whatever
um you know feel free and then you can
continue watching but anyway so all
right so this is the situation
um
okay what we're going to be talking
about today is
we're going to be using
iron lib
for this portion over here okay
in my book i give you my book
concentrates on reinforcement learning
agents and kind of explaining to you
what is reinforcement learning first
from the perspective of the environment
and then
starting in chapter three on basically
from the perspective of the agent what's
what's happening really
uh
in there
um
in reality and i do give you a lot of
pretty um i'm gonna say
um
what is the word um
implementations i would that that i hope
help you understand
the agents out of things okay now would
i use that implementation for a project
such as the the soccer environment here
probably not especially because this
environment now there is a competition
going on and by the way you guys should
share that in the in the chat
so there i think as a manchester city or
some
soccer team actually
uh
how do you call it sponsoring a
competition and you know
do well in this environment so but you
know i'm going to teach kind of like the
very basics so to get you up to speed
with rlib in this environment i'm not
going to teach you all the way to
multi-agent and all the tricks and
techniques but you know you can continue
um
so
even though i have those implementations
in here
um
i probably would not use it um
for this and that's the reason why i
install uh ira lib ray and all that
all that uh
machinery
to try to explain to you how i would do
it to compete against the big voice okay
if you want to do it you're going to do
your own dqa implementation or even my
dqm implementation or the ddpg or the
ppo it doesn't really matter uh i think
you can get a lot more
from uh our lib and i'll
tell you some of the reasons why but in
the main reason to me is the
uh the scalability aspect of it okay my
implementation uses a
you know a few cores and nothing else
not much and really uh slow
for training because all what i wanted
to do is kind of output strings so that
you uh can follow along and understand
all that stuff um but in reality
if you want to train agents and not
necessarily understand the algorithm but
just train the agent
then you need to remove all that
overhead and you know get down to
business what is the fastest way to do
multiplication this okay then use that
as opposed to you know do it the easiest
way to or the best way to understand
uh the algorithm right so there are two
different approaches anyway so we're
going to be using our lift for that and
we're going to be using
the environment i actually give you an
environment in there that i
i
kind of use i modify it from online um
but they do have a multi-agent wrapper
that you can use for our lib uh and then
the back end is gonna be the g football
uh environment that they have in there
okay
all right let's get started so far so
good let's see
no question so far okay let's proceed
all right
let's go back in here let's get back to
the paper
uh
okay
okay so
one of the coolest things is in this day
uh they if you go to this uh link over
here
they provide
they give you
the simulator
kind of you know simulator kind of ready
to do things
uh in here you can actually do multiple
things such as
you can control this guy and this guy
and this guy and this guy and this guy
you see multiple agents multiple
policies that is okay so you have a
reinforcement learning this guy can be
let's say this guy's a dqn i'm not sure
you want to do that this guy is a ppo
this guy is whatever so you can you can
really do whatever you want here okay
um i'm not saying that multi-agent
that's the best strategy but
you could um
so you know you have this uh version of
uh collaboration between
your agents it's a multi-agent problem
it's pretty good
um
you can also have
i mean you can have that that guy over
there right and then you can have
obviously you know the other team so
this guy this guy this guy this guy
those are different agents as well so
now you have collaboration and
competition at the same time so you have
a you know
11v11 in there
um i actually created a few config files
so that you can load
um in
in the simulation you can actually load
a 1v1 so there's going to be only one
it's gonna be only one player and one
side and one player on the other side
and the other player is gonna be a
computer so this is gonna be a single
agent what we're gonna do today it's
going to be a single agent
uh
training to play soccer um the one thing
is though uh i also have in there
1v1 2v2 3v3 4v4 and up to 5e5 okay so
you can once you move on from the from
the single agent uh i recommend you go
to the 2v2 and so on and try to see the
complexity try to deal with that
complexity on your own
one thing that i'm going to mention is
that i i added from so i've added all
those five
uh five um
simulation
um
scenarios
and um
from two to five
i additionally added a auto what i call
auto goalkeeper so if you play soccer
ever in video games you know that the
goalkeepers are you know pretty
um you know they have their own kind of
uh behavior uh well in reality in soccer
every player should have its own
behavior so uh i challenge you to try
the different things and try to uh
perhaps even train these agents to play
you know i'm gonna play a central
defender as this guy or a forward at
this guy but you know that's you know
you get advanced but you have the
capability with this with what they
release over here
um
so
from two to five you have the auto
goalkeeper version so in that case you
will be
one
agent a 2v2 with auto goalkeeper would
be
one agent
and one
computer so a scripted
goalkeeper
playing with you
and then that one agent will be playing
against two the scripted players
if i i hope that makes sense and 3v3
would add two agents and then one
goalkeeper and then against three
scripted agents two players and one will
keep their both scripted and then three
b3 auto goalkeeper of that four four
before auto goalkeeper b3 and and so on
okay so you have the two versions you
know go ahead and play uh with that
all right so let's get to the notebook
uh let's see how do i do this i do this
like so
yes okay cool
all right so let's see uh just make sure
we don't have can two agents share their
observation with each other oh great
question
so yes and um you know if i perhaps i'm
gonna have to do another stream to go
over the actual like the multi-agent
uh
part of it
because there are techniques
that if you think about it yourself
um
even soccer players they go out and
train you know
five days a week and then play during
the weekend right so why wouldn't you
let
um
agents share observation during training
as opposed to you know all the time
because usually you want what you want
is decentralized execution of what of a
policy that you learn what is the best
thing that i can do from this position
but
during training
many multi-agent techniques
are basically based on that of what they
call
sharing a shared critic
which you know
in some extent you can also do share
observations full observations you can
also do
things such as sharing the state of the
environment
not just observation but the full state
because if you think about it when
you're doing training
you
can know everything that you want your
training basically what you care about
uh is your performance
during your evaluation phase your
execution of your policy afterward but
if if if the goal is very well defined
such as in soccer which is win the match
you know score more than the other the
other guys you can do whatever you want
you you are open to do whatever you want
so yes you can you can share
observations usually the limitation is
when uh when is the execution portion of
of uh of the whole problem then now you
have to we need to you know talk be be
honest to each other are the agents
really going to be able to share
observations or or not in that
environment you know in soccer uh they
they don't share exactly the same field
of view right but they can communicate
so that's another thing that you add to
the whole equation so that's an
excellent question and i think you know
hopefully
um you know in the future i can go into
more detail on that
all right so people already
um
have the uh the notebook kind of going
because i am going to get going
all right let's see
all right so the first thing here that
you're gonna see is i you know well i
mean i do all the imports um there are
more imports here that you really need i
just copy and paste a bunch of stuff
from another notebook and then start
adding and removing it as i see fit here
what i'm doing is i'm i'm sending this
command to the docker container making
sure that we have these versions
you would have problems if you don't
have tensorboard 2.3 but because you
know i made the image for you you should
have exactly the same version unless you
build the image separately as opposed to
pulling the image
you build it yourself then you may get
another version if they released the
version you know two minutes ago um
but yeah not likely to happen of course
i'm kidding
um
so you know you have here some some
versions here uh if you have an uh a gpu
uh you run that command and it's gonna
tell you yes i can see the gpus
otherwise you know try to try to make
sure that you uh instead of running
docker you run nvidia docker so that the
gpu shows up uh in the in the container
um
and again
hopefully you understand how this is
actually working right now um
i have my hose machine and the hose
machine has um a a a
it has an installation of docker a
docker service
um it has the drivers of a nvidia docker
that allow allow the the gpus to be
shown up in the container
and then i'm starting this container and
then i'm mapping all these ports so that
my host machine can access
the ports to the container so that in
reality even though i'm in my host
machine this uh localhost 88 is actually
being this notebook is actually being
executed inside of the container
so i hope that makes a little bit of
sense
okay
so here is what i mentioned i created a
bunch of different
uh environments this is the 1v1 the 2v2
2v2 auto goalkeeper this will be a
single agent environment okay hope hope
it makes sense this single agent because
it has a one
auto goal keeper and one agent okay so
this one would be i would actually go
from here to the 2v2 out of goalkeeper
and see how the agent performs there
and then start doing the multi-agent the
2v2 and then go to the 3b3 and and and
then you know the auto goalkeeper and so
on here you already have
in reality i should have i should store
this you know more like this way
this is actually the the level of
difficulty that
that i would recommend for you guys for
anybody even for myself i would do
exactly so
like that and you know all these changes
i'm gonna i'm gonna save them and push
them right after this thing
uh question let's see uh i'm curious
about what state or rather observation
will be from an 11-11 game
would each
uh agent know the exact coordinates of
all other agent other 21 agents on the
field is there a way that for the agent
to only know the coordinates of other
agents within some distance from them
that's a really good question and we're
going to be flipping uh to the paper and
and kind of you know discussing those
things uh which i think are important um
i i don't know 100
for sure i like i said i actually
started uh working on this uh today i i
got excited that recently they released
this challenge and i thought hey might
as well take a look at it and see but
but i think we're gonna answer your
question uh in a minute once we start
reading the paper
all right so this step over here is
basically going to
create the soccer environment uh here
what i'm doing is i'm running 100 steps
and you can see here i'm saying hey
environment
from your action space sample and action
and then pass it to the step function so
this portion over here is basically what
i show you on that tablet um the
uh i guess i can do this
is basically
no this one ipad there you go it's
basically doing this this uh this
communication between
between these guy over here this is the
action being passed in
and then something's happening here but
i don't care about that because they
already did it for me right so the the
google uh research folks actually did
that for me and then the the environment
is gonna pass back some stuff for me
okay
um
very cool that they
let's see that okay
yeah okay
so that's what i'm doing here um
here i'm saying environment render an
image for me so that i can i want to be
able to see the the game the video game
um i grab that image i put it in a plot
and then i show the plot
right there
uh and this is what we see
uh this guy this is the other guy so if
you see my mouse hopefully you see the
little tiny things over there
we are left
the opponent is right uh this guy here
is a referee believe it or not yes they
added a referee i don't even know if the
referee is in the observations but
um i hope not
all right so
all right so the other thing that i'm
doing here now is i'm recent resetting
the environment and well the reset like
i mentioned before returns an
observation
once you reset the environment i'm
saying give me that observation and give
me the shape of the observation mostly
because i'm trying to you know get this
information you can see here that there
there are there is some um
um it seems to be an image okay and the
reason why is because i created the
environment here uh with the default
parameters which um you're well
uh
let's see where i can show you that i
can show you here
uh
the tools is a little package that i
created here uh the representation here
uh you can change it so later we're
gonna be using a vector as opposed to an
image but i didn't care too much in
there so okay so the first cool point
and now we let's switch to the uh paper
and then start kind of reading there
all right so the first
interesting point is that we have
let's see
this is the introduction of the stuff
you know so okay so here it is they they
they talk about the football engine
which is the simulation what i've been
talking about the simulation right
um
and you can do many things in there now
what kind of environment can you create
virtually if you if you are a coder you
can create anything you want okay you
already have the simulation and
simulation is a
full soccer
soccer uh simulator that allows you to
do penalty kicks free kicks and so on
right so you know give you ideas there
all the things that you can do
open source license know of the model
all right so single player
such as atari control a single player
other football environments where you
later work here it is estate and
observations
opponents so opponents and ai uh
built-in bots i was talking that the
they have auto players and you can
actually customize too you can actually
say hey i want to have
two controllable agents in
three
um
computer opponent ai what they call that
or uh
scripted agents is what i call it uh
playing in my team right so we have five
players three scripted agents two
uh reinforcement learning agents that
are learning
uh and then you can have the other team
doing something else and so on you can
customize it whichever way you want
um
state and observations here it is we
define the state as the complete set of
data that is returned by the environment
after the actions are performed on the
other hand we define observation or
representation any transformation of the
state that is provided
as an input to the control algorithms
great so this is what i was talking
about before is you know you have the
state and then you have the observation
not everybody does this for you so uh
good job guys uh let's see interrupt for
me okay so the definition of the state
contains information such as the ball
position and possession coordinates of
all the players the active players the
game state the tiriness levels of the
players yellow cars score etc
of the current
pixel frame
uh oh and the current of the current
what do you mean
and the current pixel frame great so you
have the the state contains all of the
information we need okay
everything is going to be there that
doesn't mean that your environment is
going to have to be passing that
information back to the agent your
environment is going to use the state to
create observations that you want now
they provide you with a few
uh standard observations
uh here they talk about it so three
repres we propose three different
representations two of them are pixels
ns smm
which is super minimap over here
um pixels and then the floats those are
the three okay
so the pixels
consists of these images
corresponding to the render screen this
includes both the score
and blah blah blah blah blah the super
minimap is actually what i have in here
and that's why you see the the size
um let me put back in here you can see
here the size is 72
by 96 which is basically what they have
right here 72 by 96 right and it says
consists of four
uh 72 by 96 encoding information about
the home team the away team
uh the ball the active player resp
and the active player respectively the
encoding is binary representation
sorry
representing uh whether there is
a player or ball in the corresponding
coordinate all right so
let me show you that real quick so i
said this is that
uh i can do it again here
i'm gonna okay so the observation this
one is
let's see where do i have that do i have
that
yeah there it is okay let's see if i can
regenerate that stuff
okay so this is the other kind of
observation space and the one that we're
going to be using but i'm going to go
back to the mini map in just a second i
guess i'm not sharing the screen am i
sharing the screen i'm not sharing the
screen you got to get better at that
um okay so you have the observation
there
we do the sample and look at that so now
we have
in the one so the the in the last one
i guess i probably gotta
talk about that too
so the last one is this one the the
floats representation provides provides
a compact encoding and consists of a 115
dimensional vector summarizing many
aspects of the game such as player
coordinates
ball possession
and direction and direction active
player or game
mode those for now let's see
okay so that's those are the
observations let's try to look at the
observations a little bit on
on this on the computer
um
follow me awesome
okay
all right so yeah
now we're looking at the
are we looking at what what are we
looking at
okay cool
okay so
um here i'm creating the float version
okay and if i you know go through this
you can see
i have the observation space which this
thing here is telling me uh so the the
observation space
uh
describes what the agent can
perceive the agent in this case can
perceive 115
float 32 that go that can go potentially
from minus infinite to infinite now i
challenge that that is not the case in
reality those values should have a low
and a high that are that are not
necessarily that and you know
i would argue that you know perhaps you
know i i'm sure that that information is
somewhere in the paper uh but you know
they are a little sloppy they could have
they could have just put them in and the
max in there uh that are that are
correct
um
in the case there are different means
and max you can do other kinds of
observation spaces so that you can have
the full information in there but that's
okay i mean i'm nobody's gonna
you know
i basically copy some of the code that i
have in in some example and and you know
that's what came
um okay so this observation space sample
is basically now um
generating a sample observation now when
you do this observation sample you're
not really creating
a
i'm gonna say a true sample uh of like
the game
uh it's just gonna be it's gonna be a
kind of uniform uh
uh can like a random observation based
on the observation space okay but it
doesn't mean that this value is often
this way okay so don't don't be misled
by that all right so in this case the
other cool thing is that the the action
space is very small
uh in this case it's discrete and if you
know i sample an action for instance
could be something like that right so if
i sample it again it's at zero and so on
all right so the actions are
uh
19 total actions let's uh switch to the
ipad real quick
and then
so
if we continue here we can see that the
action says
the actions available to an individual
agent player are displaying table one
which is somewhere in here thank you for
that where's the table one all right so
that's those are the actions there it is
so
the actions are like when you play the
nintendo or whatever the uh i needed oh
i'm showing my age sorry about that uh
whatever it is that people use now
playstation there you go
um
or xbox you can um
you can um um um
you have these actions right so you're
going top you're going top left
you're going bottom
uh left bottom left and so on also all
the directional
moves right
plus you do short pass high pass long
pass which are these ones over here
right and then you have the little shot
which is the square i i used to play
this a lot uh do nothing which means you
let that frame do nothing you let the
next frame come
um you also have the kind of defensive
version of these controls
so i'm not sure if you know i don't i'm
not sure if they could have reduced this
and just like when you are defending you
are using some other uh version of this
but anyway this is what they decided by
the way so i let me
let me
say it again
you can do whatever you want with it
right so you have the simulator in the
back end you can customize this to make
to your liking okay i'm not saying that
that is where i would spend my time but
you could if you want it
okay so let's see so those are table one
okay they include standard move action
say directions
and different ways to kick the ball
short long passes shooting high passes
that can be easily intercepted along the
way of course
also players can sprint which affects
their level of tiredness that's cool
try to intercept the ball with a slight
tackle or dribble if they possess the
ball let's see okay so they do that if
they obsess the ball
we experimented with an action to switch
the active player in defense
otherwise the player with the ball must
be active
of course when it's in offense right
uh defense okay so however we serve the
policies tending to exploit this action
to return control to the built
in ai behavior for non-active players oh
i see that
and we decided to remove it from the
action sets we do not implement
randomized sticky actions
instead once executed moving and
sprinting
actions
are sticky and continue until the
explicit stop action is performed stop
moving stop sprint respectively oh
that's interesting that's cool okay
so here
so randomized sticky actions is
something that was done in atari uh that
as i suppose is the the action repeat
basically
um and sometimes like the actions
basically repeat for a number of frames
whether you want it or not but obviously
in this case i would not be cool because
if you probably always i don't know if
you ever play uh
uh soccer and sometimes you kind of
slide and then slide again and then all
of a sudden it's a red car for you know
doing a sticky action and you didn't
want to slide twice you just wanted to
slide when the wall was coming and
whatever so it makes sense here so
that's actually good all right so that's
that
and we're gonna go to the rewards in a
second but let's uh let's get back to
the computer
here
okay so let's see
all right so i already showed these two
the next thing we need to do is and i
wanted to show you this so just so that
you you are aware of it again oh let's
see uh
questions
so do we have continuous and discrete
in each action in environment
uh do we have continuous and discrete
action equals continue discrete
no so the action is a discrete so it's a
one it's a is a
discrete and it's only single a single
value right so and it's going to be a
value you think about it is a zero a one
or a two or a three or a four that's it
and each number is going to mean
something else
to the player
down the simulator does that make sense
cool
outstanding all right so i wanted you
guys to um
have these hopper uh environment here
because like you know lahai is asking
there
you know
it may be disappointed disappointing to
have a an action space that is such as
such as that one in this one for
instance there's an environment called
called the the hopper
uh you can see here this is a little bit
you know better prepared
action space
you have the minimum value of minus one
the maximum value of uh one and then you
have three floats
one
two three and these three floats mean
something you know different it's gonna
one is gonna control the knee of the
hopper and you know we can very very
quickly
uh hopper oh it's hopper environment
no environment
uh
reinforcement learning all right so
hopper environment reinforcement
learning in this case this is the the
mujoku one but is this a little funny
dude so you're probably controlling this
joint that joint and some other thing
right or the little little motor there
yeah this guy so the the
the one that i'm uh you you can try to
train in that one too uh but the one
that i'm doing is the is the one that is
called bullet
bullet
like that bullet hopper environment
uh bullet
ah maybe i don't know
anyway it's uh very similar and i
actually use it in my book in case that
you
um that you wanna oh look at that that's
my book
uh okay cool
let's go back in there all right so but
yeah i wanna just to let you know that
in this case for instance the hopper
environment has 15 variables for the
observation space and three for the
action space so you know sometimes it
would be nice to have all of the actions
right because you're like you know going
up and also making a pass at the same
time and then so you know the ability to
have all those actions at once may i
don't know may change stuff right so i
don't know but um in atari they solved
that by just basically combining the
actions which i don't think they did
that but um
stop screen left right maybe not but
that's okay
all right so okay proceed all right
okay so that's a temp environment just
to show you that now
uh this is the real stuff so when i do
environment reset here uh you can see
now an actual array with some values in
there uh and let me see if i can they
probably have the
an appendix with all of the variables
if i find it i share
okay i don't have it right now but um
but that's okay we can
uh
you know there are ways to find out what
each of these values really mean which
you know uh
when you when you start getting serious
i would recommend you do that to see if
you really want to pass information here
you can see there are a lot of minus
ones there are a lot of zeros
and only a few
you know non minus one nonzero variables
what does that mean does that mean that
we could trim this down to something
much much much smaller
uh my guess is yes i would say yes there
is definitely some way to actually
uh uh you know trim down this
observation space but you know for the
time being we're just going to proceed
that way all right so here i'm doing
advancing the simulation a little bit
and the reason why i do this is just
kind of to try to observe what the age
where the environment has you know after
a few steps of the simulation and you
can see that you know for the most part
there is a lot of garbage in there that
you could actually trim that observation
space to
uh bare minimums
again and something that you would have
to research i don't i don't have i
didn't find it in the paper we're going
to go back to the paper in a second just
to talk about the rewards and so on
um but i'm sure that is somewhere in the
um in the google research uh portion of
things right so if you do google
research
that guy
i'm sure that there somewhere you can
actually find
uh how they create the environment and
what they're actually passing you know
here the observation
yeah i wouldn't do that right now
because
we're already one hour and i'm not even
halfway there
we got seven seven folks people are
leaving okay all right so but that's
okay let's uh let's continue to see what
we can do here all right the reward in
this case is zero the done is false uh
information there's some information and
so on so that's actually interesting and
now what we can do is actually now step
through the sample environment for five
episodes and see what happens okay
and i do that
um and you can see how
starting to do its thing
let's see
cool so here what i'm doing is
um
uh
so i start the environment here i reset
the environment get the new observation
i'm calculating the return which is the
the sum of all of the rewards in the
episode and then i set the uh done flag
to false i run for five episodes and i'm
gonna pull three videos to look at
what's in there okay you can see here
there's a little progress bar and here
you have the you know episode zero
return zero uh episode one uh return
minus three episode two minus one and so
on so obviously here as you can see i'm
basically having a random agent the
agent is really not doing anything
interesting and i don't expect the agent
to do well i just want to show you what
what it looks like okay so uh in the
docker container i can pass in this this
command to actually show show
uh the output of the videos that i
created okay
uh i created a little helper function
that allows you to display
how that those videos
look like and now you can see basically
what the agent is really doing in the
environment okay so now is processing is
is basically
if you have trouble with that function
is because of memory issues uh so make
sure that you know you have a
workstation or
if you have a uh uh if you don't have a
workstation then i recommend you go here
to the gifts gift tools and then try to
play with this guy this guy and this guy
kind of reduce the scale of the video
so that uh you don't run out of memory
uh before so you know what bit locker is
no i don't uh
i'll look at that later let's see uh
but okay let's uh let me see if i
continue here all right here you can see
there is a g
uh this is the goalkeeper and the other
goalkeeper it doesn't really matter
they're not you know
doing anything that's the ball you can
see how we are the left guy
uh they're you know they have some kind
of automatic behavior so even though
it's random uh when there's a a
particular action being pressed then the
agent has a
a you know wants to basically close
uh to the ball all right so that's why
you see the agent going to the ball and
then kicking it and then going to the
ball and kicking it because there's the
auto you know behavior in there
uh yeah so i print a couple of trials
there so for for you to look at
and then um
let's see so here
uh
one other thing that is important to do
and now i'm gonna get into the into the
our lib side of things
is you know make sure that you have x
number of processors
uh and you know have that in mind
because we're gonna be using processor
above
not just the actual cpu but the number
of processors processors that are
available to linux
uh the the
the docker container is a linux machine
and then you know there are so many uh
processors processors that are gonna be
available and you're gonna use that uh
to train okay
in my case i have 32 it's a you know
pretty pretty leafy processor uh i could
go all the way here to almost like 30
right and it would be pretty big uh
pretty uh fine
here i'm going to be
training a carpel example okay just to
demonstrate what our lib is
in this case i'm using so our ellipse
actually initialized
on startup when you start the
the the docker container it's gonna come
up with our lib and all that stuff and
you can see here it's gonna come up also
with tensorboard and it's gonna come up
with uh the ray dashboard
so that you can monitor
the use of the resources in your machine
now this one is not as important this
one is very very cool and important and
you're going to see what happens okay so
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to run
a ppo agent as you can see here
we're telling it
run a carpal environment
use one gpu for training use
a workers and this is going to be like
the
you know
uh the parallel execution of rollouts
uh so the eight workers are going to be
uh sampling their policies and going
through some
episodes collecting that data and then
moving that data
centralizes for the trainer to grab
batches of data and then train
churn the data cree and improve the
policy and then redistribute the weights
so that the new the workers can use new
and improved uh versions of the policies
and so on
okay the
the episode uh so here is the stop
criteria that i'm using i'm using i'm
saying hey when the episode reward me
reaches 150 then stop now if you if
you're not familiar with uh
the uh the carpool environment which i
would be shocked if you're not i
recommend you look in uh you know in my
book and then come back to this is the
player rewarded for getting closer to
the ball yes and uh we're gonna go over
that in a second
um all right so
uh here the only parameters that i'm
changing is the the learning rate i'm
saying you know use use that or tuning
that stuff
we go there
and we see what happens uh it's you know
it's grabbing nine pros processes out of
32 that are available in the machine one
gpu out of two gpus available uh so you
see i can actually use more here is
gravity because a uh nine as opposed to
eight because eight are for workers and
one is for the training
trainer
okay you can see here
uh the training happening and then if
you flip to tensorboard and you know
sometimes you're gonna have to refresh
you're gonna see stuff coming up okay
beautiful this is actually why i like
our lib uh because they have all this
built in uh you don't have to
do this yourself um you train one of
these agents and all of the information
shows up in here you can actually use
tensorboard uh and just
regex in syntax in this case uh you know
the thing that i want to look at is the
reward meme okay so here you see that
that my agent is learning he's going up
boom boom boom boom this is what we look
for this is what we want this means that
the
episode reward which is the return
uh the mean return
across multiple
agents multiple uh workers that are
rolling out that stuff so that's why is
the mean
um
is you know at this particular time is
161 and the smooth value is
131 you can see it there right so the
smoothness depends on this guy over here
i can say you know hey you can
you know i want to use a very
um you know i want to be very quick safe
that my value is is well um
what the value is saying there or you
know you can say no whatever so um
here you know i
i don't need to smooth that value i just
want the true value uh in my graph
sometimes when you have multiple uh
um
when you have a very noisy environment
this can be like super super noisy up
and down right so using the smoothing is
actually helpful in that in that sense
all right so you can see here it's
terminated i run it for very little
um there's not much in here so this is
this is our live what i'm showing you
here our lib is a reinforcement learning
um
i'm going to say framework package
that is based on rey
ray
is pretty good at distributing jobs
across multiple
so if you have multiple servers you can
actually do that in a really nice way
now the cool thing is that you don't
need to have a farm of servers to
actually use our lab as you can see here
i'm not only
using
ray in our lib in in a docker container
in a single machine but also in a docker
container so it's very very restricted
in this case
however
um it is very easy to scale so for the
most part that is transparent to you
so you can iterate using a local machine
and once you're confident and you're
happy with what you have you basically
say hey now i'm going to send to the
cloud to aws and train for a few hours
and boom you know back you you get your
your thing right so this case we're
local again uh but uh i think ray is
really useful for these kinds of uh
projects so here are some two locations
that i would recommend looking into
the temp logs are going to be the
training logs and you can see here the
the
the ls command actually returns a carpal
folder mostly because i
organize the experiments
uh so all of the experiments that run
with this thing are going to be
organized there in the carpool category
okay if i have more experiments i would
have many different ones right in in
this uh in this location over here and
then the other interesting thing that
you may want to look into is the temp
array session
latest and logs and here you get all the
array
uh specific logs and some of these are
interesting to look at you can see here
the python
course so these are the workers and
basically the workers can have
information about the environment
whatever you output in your environment
you may actually get uh through some of
these workers
uh and so you know it's pretty pretty
good um
uh to when you're trying to troubleshoot
you're creating an environment i
recommend you you know look into these
locations so right now here i'm
basically removing all the logs the
training stuff so then uh tensorboard
should just be clear at this point and
it is and then i move on all right so
now we're gonna we're gonna get a little
bit more advanced on
our lib and then we're gonna back we're
gonna go back uh to talk about the
rewards
of the uh
the soccer environment and then we're
gonna train a soccer agent okay
so
this in here is a little bit more
complex you can see i added a few more
stop criteria i said hey i want only 10
training iterations and this number can
vary depending on a variety of things so
i'm not going to get too much into it
but it depends on the number of uh the
size of the rollout the the the number
of batches that you're collecting for
sampling from your replay buffer and
how many uh stochastic graded descent
iterations you apply every training
iteration and so on so
you know i'm not going to get into that
detail right now
but what i'm going to say is
you know this value is perhaps confusing
and you know i probably would remove it
uh for
for other purposes
but i wanted to show you that you can
actually define multiple uh stopping
criterias the same stopping criteria
here of episode reward 195
uh rewards but because we're going to be
doing a search so we're going to try to
train an agent that is really good
so the search uh then i want to block
the agent from going beyond
so any worker
uh or uh no sorry not worker
um
the entire training should not exceed
50 50 000 time steps total of experience
that means multiple workers are going to
be sampling their experience and so on
the accumulation of all of those should
not exceeds 50 000 time steps
and then in this case is the
accumulation of the of uh the episodes
should not exceed um 500. okay
uh you can see here i'm actually doing
the same carpal this is the carpal
environment right there i'm saying like
hey pick a gamma between this and this
and you can see here this is a sampling
that you can do uniform now i'm not
doing this because i recommend that you
play too much with gamma
i'm only doing this because to give you
the information of what you can do with
this okay uh and then you can also do
the the grid search which is more like
you you know fix this value i want this
value to be tested i want this value to
be tested and this value is tested
usually the way i do it is that i start
with a very wide grid search
uh
experiment and then i run a white
experiment to kind of have a ballpark of
what values i should be using
once you get the ballpark that's what
what are you norm i normally use one i
use one once i have a ballpark that is
you know narrow then i do the kind of
tuning with the with the uniform stuff
between this and this value that's
what's you know best so i would do it
that way
uh there are other uh training
techniques such as population based
training and you know and advanced
things patient stuff and our lib
actually has those things the the
scheduler um they have a different a few
different classes but you can actually
just you know google it uh population
based training are a lib and you're
gonna get to their documentation page
you could try to implement that in here
too as well and then you know put it
later it's i think you know if you are
planning to you know get started and
then go try to do the the contest then
i'll definitely try a more advanced
uh hyper parameter search than just a
grid search
okay
so in this case i'm using seven
workers and the reason why i'm doing
that is because this is gonna run one
two three times three is that what it's
gonna run
[Music]
three times
that i think so
uh and then so if i use a fewer workers
than the workers i have available i'm
able to actually use well i guess my
limitation is gonna be the gpu but i'm
gonna be able to um
basically
yeah there you are so there are all of
those here
um
i'm gonna be using you know more cpus
so and then in a little bit i'm probably
going to start utilizing the two gpus
there it is and then now 16. so i could
even do a little bit more i think you
know
i'm being nice to to the computer
okay
so while we do that
i'm going to switch and continue
discussing now the rewards because we're
going to be training that stuff in just
a minute
so somebody asked
does the agent get a
um
a reward for getting closer to the ball
sort of uh and here's the the detail
right the details are
all right so rewards
the football agent includes two reward
functions that can be used out of the
box
so here's here's the key point
they can be used out of the box that
doesn't mean that you have to use that
so most of the work if you if you want
to
uh you know
experiment with this i would say is to
implement your own reward function
um
[Music]
here's the caveat right so the more you
add to the reward function the faster
your agent learns almost all the time
there are some kinds of reward functions
that are called and this is our paper
out there by andrew eng
when he was a student
but there is a potential base
potential based
shaping
which is a way that supposedly well i
mean when not supposedly when you are in
the discrete state in action spaces so
in the simple case uh the if you
implement that type of reward shaping
your policy
is invariant so the optimal policy and
for for the
environment
that that the original environment and
the environment that uh that you modify
basically by adding new rewards is the
same
which is really good because this means
basically you're not adding bias uh to
that now in the world of deep learning
that all goes
down the drain it doesn't really matter
you have a neural network nothing
there's no theory they're helping you
okay but the idea is is still there
i i wanna let's see um yeah i wanna talk
about the
the
the rewards they have uh so that you can
have an idea an example but i would
recommend you you add your own okay
so here you have one
and then here's the other one the the
first one the scoring corresponds to the
natural reward where the teammates up
things are plus one when scoring the
goal and a minus one when conceiving one
great okay
uh the scoring reward can be hard to
observe during initial stage stages of
training so they're explaining here why
they're gonna be adding reward
additional reward and this is a very
common problem in enforcement learning
usually
you want to say like hey you know
make me a million dollars i give you a
plus one and it's not that easy right
so you have to usually work a little bit
more to actually give it more so the one
of the things in alphago alpha 0 and all
those uh versions or actually i think it
was alpha 0 it's actually that it was
rewarded to you know it didn't have much
shaping it just had a plus one for you
know winning the game zero when he tied
and then minus one for losing right so
uh that that is why it was a very um
uh
a popular i'm gonna say uh
accomplishment right
um
let's see so this current work can be
hard to assert in national center and
may require a long sequence of
consequent events overcoming the defense
yeah so potentially strong opponent
potentially and scoring a goes to a
keeper okay the second uh reward
is is shaped and so when you see this
word over here shape that's what is
that's what it means is that you do have
that one and you have the minus one but
you're going to give him a little bread
crumbs to the agent you're gonna say hey
you know what if you do this thing i'll
give you a 0.1 if you do that i'll give
you a 0.2 and whatever
the problem with this is
well let's let's read this and then i'll
tell you the problem with doing this
this this whole thing okay
um all right so reward that it
specifically addresses the sparsity of
scoring by encoding the domain knowledge
that scoring is aided by advance across
the pitch okay so
it augments well
so you see it's like so what they're
doing here
is they are they're going to
add an
auxiliary contribution for moving the
ball close to the opponent goals in a
controlled fashion
more specifically we divide the
opponent's field in tank checkpoints
regions according to the euclid distance
to the opponent's goal
okay so i guess you know you have the
goal there like do you have
you know this midfield this is your goal
this is their goal they do 10 things in
here and then they every time that you
enter
says here the first time that the agent
the the agent's team possesses the ball
in each of the checkpoint regions the
agent obtains an additional reward of
plus one so you know plus zero well plus
zero one sorry
this extra reward can be added up to
plus one
the same as scoring the single goal
okay and then another caveat there any
non-collected checkpoint is also added
when scoring in order to avoid
penalizing agents that do not go through
all checkpoints before scoring right so
because so imagine that the agent shoots
from here and then you know scores the
goal and now suddenly the agent is not
going to have that
right so it's not going to have this
this and this it makes no sense right so
you really the goal is to score so if
you score even from here it doesn't
matter i'll give you the you know plus
two as opposed to
um you know only you know
plus point or i guess one point
two which would be
not exactly what you want the agent is
always going to prefer to you know drive
all the way and then shoot from here but
you know pros and cons okay
um
let's see so let's see if i don't miss
anything here any connection awards also
when scoring when they're putting icing
the agents they go through all the
chickens
finally checkpoint checkpoint rewards
are only given once per episode
okay right so because i don't want the
agents to get cl you know in a loop
basically you can imagine the agent
going like oh look at that if i go here
and then you know just you know oh go
out and go back and go out and go back
and that's not the behavior that you
want so that makes sense
now here's my thing
is does it make this
shaping maybe maybe not
uh
the problem is that often in
reinforcement learning what you want is
the agent to find stuff that you cannot
find then the more you add rewards the
more you're adding bias to the agent
right like you know if you like soccer
you understand what i'm saying they're
so team some teams play
um the possession game right pass the
ball and then pass tick tick tock tick
whatever they call it right so passing
back and passing to the side and then to
the side and then controlling control
and control but they end up they end up
losing the game because they are not
scoring more than the opponent is that
a good thing to to do like you know
700 passes per game is that what we want
no so
that's kind of caveat there right so
you're when you're adding the extra
reward
um then
you perhaps are going to be biased your
behavior is going to be biased it's not
something that you want
so
often you got to be very careful with
this the other thing that you have to be
careful with is that usually shaping
in some cases if you say oh plus one for
you know moving the ball then you're
going to have different things the agent
is never going to want to
shoot the ball like if you have you know
imagine this thing over here
um
and if say let's say that instead of uh
um
0.1 we are actually doing a
a one a whole one right
uh then the agent has much more value by
well
by um
you know controlling the ball and then
shooting all the way collecting all
those wants unless you know what they
did there the adding all the checkpoints
that they didn't
uh that that the agent didn't go through
with the goal which you know it also
makes sense um now for instance with
that reward function the agent is always
going to prefer
to shoot from here
and you say why what what are you
talking about why would that be they're
giving the reward because there is such
a thing as a discount factor right so
they're not the little thing gamma
and again if you know what you're
talking what i'm talking about i highly
recommend you go get the book and
uh and try to read those things so you
understand what's happening here the
agent is going to say well you know it
takes me so much time to go all the way
here
and then shoot the ball
so as opposed to me waiting all that
time
and discounting the value of the reward
that i'm getting because you know the
agent is gonna it's gonna be
here it would go it would get the 0.1
0.1
0.1 so many steps right like imagine 500
steps all the way until it gets here and
then he shoots that and he gets the plus
one okay
imagine that that was 500 steps
so what is this gamma value going to
look like like a tiny tiny tiny little
value right and then when you multiply
that
to to calculate the value function
of the initial state the first state
when the game starts
that contribution is going to be so
small
to that value okay hopefully you're
understanding what i'm saying
so
if you are here
and shoot from here
the shooting i am i'm assuming is much
faster so you boom and then the ball
gets there uh so let's say that that
takes you know 100 steps as opposed to
500 when you're dribbling
500 step 100 steps then the discounted
and then you're gonna receive
a 0.1 here and then in in 100 steps
a plus two right so the value here is
likely
um the contribution to the value
function is likely higher uh and you
know you could actually calculate these
things and you know if we were doing a
serious thing i would probably calculate
that to make sure that i'm not going
crazy i would actually sample make sure
that i'm
um
that i'm um
you know my assumptions are actually
correct right so i would actually sample
the environment see oh is this 500 steps
or 200 steps and how long does it take
to shoot from here and here and so on
but yeah so things to have in mind okay
so that's the rewards
that's it let's flip back to the
computer
um let's see and uh please if you have
any questions let me know be happy to
answer you guys still there yes all
right so yeah crad is the player
rewarded for getting closer to the ball
so he's not rewarded for getting closer
to the ball although he could but he's
rewarded for getting the ball closer or
actually
going through the opponent's feel which
is you know an interesting take but
you know perhaps your idea of getting
closer to the ball is better
i recommend in that case that you check
uh the video uh georgia tech videos of
uh
it's called messing with rewards
the rldm course by the way i have those
videos also on my youtube channel so
just go ahead and look for that one is a
class by uh professor
uh charles isabel and michael lintman
and
they discuss
actually a very similar uh
game actually was a soccer game but not
with this but with some other uh
simulator but yeah
all right so look at that so training
has finished you can see here we have
all of the different
trials all right so each guy here each
row is a trial
and now you can see here
each trial
was sampled with a different gamma and
that's because i said mp random uniform
from between 0.9 to 1.
now their learning rate as you can see
is the grid search
0.002
here serial procedure to zero percent
two now
it did this guy then this guy then this
guy and he did it three times because of
his number of samples
okay
i hope that makes sense because it's
important so once you are actually
playing with the environment in a little
bit more depth then you know i would
actually do when every night that you're
done you just like
leave a lot of samples running and see
what it is what is the
punishment if players take bad action
was a good question i think according to
what i see there is no punishment
uh but
the goals right so the you get score on
and then you're gonna get minus one now
i did see a higher re
lower return i i should say
so i'm thinking perhaps the
the um
[Music]
if the opponent goes through your
uh
side of the your side of the field
perhaps you get a minus 0.1 when the
opponent is getting at 0.1 i don't know
that would be a good thing to check
that's a good question actually
okay so
again uh we have all the different ones
and this is the things that that you
care about here in this case is the
reward
um that's the value then the reward max
reward mean and episode mean
uh and if we go to the tensorboard and
this is when thirst tensorboard board
becomes a very very helpful tool
is that you can now see
your different runs right and then in
this case is is the carpal environment
and i use
pretty okay values so it you know i
would say now it's not really that
helpful you know
uh because
what is the variance there and i would
you know likely
run many many more and much wider values
and then you would have actually here
you would have actually something that
would tell you that that would inform
you
of which values you should be using and
which ones you shouldn't
um
but yeah that's the test that i wanted
to show you okay so
once you
train
here with tune run
you're going to return a an object that
is the um kind of analysis like it's
they call it i don't know i forget the
name exactly but you know if i run that
you're going to see your have a few
functions so there a is going to give
you the functions of this particular
object
and some of the things that you have in
there is the best checkpoint the best
config the best data frame best log
there and so on so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to with that object i'm
going to get the best trial out of the
trials that
um that are in there and i'm going to
get the max
episode mean
that's how that's the criteria that i'm
gonna use to get the best trial
and then i'm gonna use that best trial
to get the best checkpoint of that best
trial
uh so i'm gonna get the best checkpoint
with the same criteria and i'm sure that
it should be some function that does
that in one step for you but i didn't
find it didn't have much time so
here is the
uh the checkpoint look at that so
checkpoint nine checkpoint nine this
this is the uh tensorflow checkpoint
this is your
the policy so basically what we're
saying here is that these are the
weights
of the policy that got the highest
reward so this is what you want to use
to compete in other words
so in this case
you know i got that
and then what i'm doing is now config
ppo
default config copy what i'm doing here
is i'm grabbing a config a ppo config
i'm saying don't use any workers to make
sure that i'm just going to roll out i'm
just going to use the policy
to
[Music]
to ask the policy what action should i
use given this particular state in
reality this particular observation so
you know here
observation as opposed to state
but then i run this guy
and here you can see the episodes coming
back right the return is 200 to 100 to
100 200 so i'm basically saying that the
agent is doing a perfect job at what is
supposed to do in this case is the
carpool
i can actually you know run this command
here to see my agent perform in the
carpool environment
and
now
uh voila you're gonna have there the uh
the age so the agent is controlling that
in a perfect way so that's it great cool
okay so now we know how to do that
with a carpool we know now we know the
the google uh
football environment we know our lib now
we pull this things together okay and
then we're gonna train
uh
the
the ppo agent but uh to uh solve this
so here um
in this case i i want to uh give you
bring to your attention that sometimes
the number of policies and the number of
agents are two different things
you could have a single policy
controlling all of your agents
uh and that policy would be
you know using observations from all of
the different agents and not combined in
a single way but more like you know you
can imagine that you're moving the agent
on different
um
moving the agent to different players
and then controlling each player that
way
okay
and then so
those are two different things
and it's up to you to kind of you know
play around with that
uh here i'm doing the simple case which
is you know one policy and this is a
single
agent case
uh here this is a way when you need to
register
an environment
uh with ir live so that you can use it
so i register it here this little hack
here is that you know sometimes you want
to delete the environment if you replay
this cell multiple times you would
actually have an issue because the
environment has not been deleted so just
add it there so delete it if
it exists otherwise don't you know the
complaint and if didn't exist just don't
complain i don't i don't care
so here you can see i'm passing uh this
is a helper function you can see the
helper function in here and play with it
this is a class
again half credit to
the the google uh folks because they
they're they provided uh
you know most of this
interface i would spend more time
polishing it
if you want to continue working on it
here i get the observation space and the
action space from the perspective of a
single agent
and then i generate the policies like so
these are policies that are going to be
later
if you're doing a multi-agent training
you're going to be having to use this if
you have multiple policies in this case
it's a single policy so i'm not getting
too into that complexity so far
but um
there you see it
we confirm that the action space is that
the observation space is that then you
have those policies you can see here is
a single policy so it's not a big deal
policies ids are those right now i'm
clearing the
the logs so that these guys go away
because it's not a carpool anymore you
can also leave it they are going to be
organized by by the experiment name but
i rather not
complicate those things
and
that's it so here's one thing
this training takes time
and i'm obviously not going to be
sitting here for two hours waiting for
the training to complete
i i will however uh
switch to uh to a q a
uh after this
uh but i'm only gonna do let's see like
200 200 000
uh 250 000 steps so that would take
probably 10 15 minutes or so
uh and then i'm gonna wrap up
now here
i would say you know train
once we're done go ahead and train with
five million by yourself right it's not
a big deal you can see here that the
episode mean now i'd lower it to two
um you know you can play with that
i also make the gamma a fixed value a
learning rate is there it's a single
sample you can do a grid search the way
that i show over there you can see here
that i'm using 30 workers you're gonna
have to use lower that number of course
it's too much or unless you have you
know 32 like i do
but other than that these are other
things that you want to kind of become
familiar with
checkpoint frequency is the number of
iterations
uh so every 10 iterations training
iterations whatever that means again
that's a little harder to understand but
that's okay
every 10 training iterations i'm going
to create a checkpoint okay
additionally i'm going to create a
checkpoint at the end regardless
if if it ended up at exactly a 10 or a
the third iteration it doesn't matter
i'm gonna create that final checkpoint
when when this thing gets hit which is
the either this guy or this guy right
um the number
so i'm gonna keep
three
checkpoints of those guys and i'm gonna
use this the episode reward mean as a
score attribute basically
our liv is gonna do it for me it's going
to look at the highest episode reward
mean checkpoints and our is going to
keep the highest three at any given time
right so that's actually super useful
because you know
all you need to do is train this puppy
and um
yeah it's going to start showing here in
any second
see the resource so cpu
being utilized
rams kicking in there and the disc
let's see
okay
it's coming is coming
there it is
and
that's it it's it's running so you can
see here so far it's not uh there's not
a
full episode so when you see the nine in
there usually means that it hasn't
completed
a single one and already collected a
bunch of data but it's not um
able to
get
get the statistics because of this the
size
but in any second this thing gets
becomes
just regular numbers
and then at the end of the um
of the notebook you're gonna see that i
basically
customize everything else so that you
can do the same thing that i did with a
carpal
environment but with this other
environment and it's a little bit
different but you know there the
functions are in there uh again you're
gonna see here you're gonna get the
checkpoint of that guy
so the important thing is that this
object over here is going to contain all
that all that information you're going
to get the checkpoint
then you're going to load the checkpoint
into a policy into an agent here ppo
trainer
uh you load that guy
and then you create the policy and then
you have a little function that is like
you know give me the action for
this particular state
um
then here i'm creating a single instance
so a single agent of that environment
just so that i can a single agent how do
i say like an independent environment so
that i can run it one step at a time
reset in there just to see what the
information comes look at this is
actually this actually has a key value
pair
and the introduction to multi-agent nrl
and again you know i'm way over my time
but
i'm going to say that when you're doing
a multi-agent rl i recommend you look at
our libs interface so openai created
that uh open igm interface for single
agent when you have multiple multiple
agents then you know the problem a
problem shows up like okay what is the
observation what is the reward like how
do i know which reward goes to which
agent and so on
so
our lib came up with the another
interface uh which is you know pretty
straightforward and you know also also i
guess other folks also came up with the
same interface anyway but what people
use for multi-agent is a key it's a
dictionary
as opposed to
let me put it here let me go back to
this guy
okay you can see that
so remember the agent you can you can
imagine here now we're gonna have the
agent
you know agent a one
agent
two
agent three and then you have a single
environment
environment
an environment wants to talk to this guy
and give him something
and wants to receive
something from that guy as well
so
okay wants to receive the action and
know that that is the action and this
but
this system of doing it
um
independently like this it's a little
cumbersome because you want something
you want it to be synchronized right
so what people do often is um
um
you know you can imagine something like
this
um
imagine these are like the policies
these guys over here are the policies
and then you have here like like an
actual you know like a main agent not
quite i'm hopeful this is probably not
the best way to explain this but let me
proceed and then try to clarify it
um so you can have here the environment
and what's going to happen is the
environment
and the agent now are going to be
communicating through
dictionaries right so you know a
dictionary is going to have a key
agent one
and then something
right and then
and and then agent
two
[Music]
and then something and so on right
so now
this guy is gonna pass the environment
the key value pair
that contains the actions for for the
for each of the agents that are
available in there now the advanced
multi-agent stuff agents can come in and
come out at any given time in reality
uh you can think of agents showing up
like uh let's say oh actually let's
imagine that this soccer game has
substitutions right
and then a new agent comes in in the you
know 60th minute right
so you want to be able to reflect that
and then agents can come in in and out
now in in this particular environment i
don't think that they have that
available i highly doubt it
um
but you know that would be an
interesting thing if they had that but
um i i i don't think we need to worry
about that for uh for this environment
now when when you return stuff instead
of returning observations rewards
dawns and infos
each of these guys are going to be a key
value pair
that is going to have the the key
is going to be the agent
that should get that observation and the
value is going to be the actual
observation that the agent should get
and then here the same with the reward
reward and then the same with the dawn
and the same with the info
every single little thing has the same
thing the same kind of interface so this
guy here in the middle is going to say
oh never mind you go ahead and let me
give you your stuff let me give you your
stuff your stuff and then give me your
stuff i accumulate and then send it to
the environment and so on
so that is how the multi-agent is done
and that's why you see the format that i
have in there
let me flip back again
the format
excuse me
the format that i have in here is agent
zero and then that is the observation
okay and then later you're gonna see
here that i'm actually doing now
uh you know agent zero i need to
actually now index that with the agent
zero and then the don all means that
when every agent is done because you
know that the agents can be so if you
imagine that you have
11 players
and they get substituted in the 60th
minute
then a few agents are going to be done
but not all of the agents are going to
be done
so the
underscore underscore the don underscore
underscore all
is going to be telling every single
agent you guys are done like this is
done for real type of thing so that is
the interface i kind of explain it to
you now with all that
but if you run the code here go down the
line you're basically gonna go down to
this
and you're gonna see your agent doing
something a little bit better than you
know than what i was doing before now
it's not perfect this one is actually i
train it for very little
but um
and again i'm not i haven't
tuned the hyperparameters of this
particular environment
and i don't like that
the episode reward me is actually going
down
uh but no when i when i run it for 500
500 000 half a mill i think i run it for
a hun for half a million it was starting
to go up so
the value should get you going
um but uh obviously
you can customize it and make it better
now i'll give you a few tips here that
what you can try
uh an agent such as the ppo agent has
multiple different
um
knobs that you can tune
so go ahead and take a look at it
actually this is what i recommend you do
ppo that pod let's say this page over
here is what's going to give you the
information of what the agent really
does and what you can actually fine-tune
it look use critic true use uh
generalized advantage estimation and you
would have to go read the paper here to
get more information
lambda
kl coefficient
these are kind of more training hyper
parameters but this is you know so the
the training iteration depends on these
values for instance
you have the shuffle stuff the learning
rate
uh share values all this stuff and in my
book
i talk about these things okay so my
my book tries you know i try to explain
all of these things
um
actually allow you to implement it again
i mean obviously sorry commercial time
right
uh
go ahead and get it grock indeed
reinforcement learning so chapter 12
actually talks about ppo this particular
algorithm
so i i highly recommend that if you're
going to be using this go here otherwise
if you want to use some other algorithm
i know a lot of people are familiar with
other algorithms such as dqn whatever go
there go to the dqn
uh and then open
and apply
and
and that's it you're going to be able to
you know look at their values their
stuff the buffer size the prioritized
replay buffer
uh the target network frequency update i
also teach that in my book uh chapter
perhaps ten i don't know ten nine i
think it's eight nine ten all of those
so the dqm chapters highly recommend you
go there oh let me see okay we got
questions
uh what's the punishment you said are
the agents
i didn't share the weight like ddpg a2c
of the model when
it has been configured as one policy
multi-agents yes
so
um
so there are two layers there right so
you have
workers the rollout workers and those
guys are you know you know share uh
in a more
timely fashion they're all synchronized
and then the objects go like that and so
on when you're doing
um i guess this goal is independent
um
so it's a single agent controlling all
different
um
players of the game
then you can also share
uh observations now the only caveat that
i'm gonna mention there is that
some you can you can think about this
right so off policy learning
may be an issue here okay and usually a
non-stationary is also gonna be an issue
but
um
you know if you have a replay buffer
something like uh like a dqn or a ddpg
actually that you're that you're saying
in there but though though this
environment has a discrete uh action
space so i would probably use a dqn or
a2c with a with a policy that outputs
discrete actions um
then if it is off policy then you can
use data from basically any
um you know agent
and he would actually
be okay learning with that
uh if you don't use if you're gonna be
using a ppo you may have problems there
now
our lib already works that out for you
and then when you do a training like
this like like a multiple policy then
they you know they fix some of that
stuff for you with the with the
observations okay so
um
so it's like sharing yes and then so
will the same observation be stored
multiple times equal to the number of
agents in the replay buffer
um
from the perspective of that other agent
so
in the case that the agents and i don't
think this is the case but if the agents
look at the the game as the whole frame
then yes it's going to be exactly the
same in the replay buffer which is
probably you are intuitively asking that
that's why you're asking the question
not a good idea
um then then yes i would probably fix
that but i think the the 115
vector should probably be different
uh for every
um uh player
so those were are not going to be
identical right it's not the same
observation it's gonna be this from the
same time step of the simulation but
from the perspective of each of those
players right you have 11 players it's
gonna be from the perspective of the uh
goalkeeper what is happening from the
perspective of the striker what is
happening and so on
hope that makes sense
all right so let's see how the training
is
going
okay we're going up finally i was like
oh no
look at that that only happens on
streams right like
no it starts going up and then uh you
know i around the million then starts uh
going all the way up
um
and you can see here is the max is
actually going sharp up which uh that's
another thing that you can do is like
if the max goes up like this
and then the agent gets stuck basically
to that kind of max
something good is happening okay so then
then then you can expect the mean to
start going up up up up
depending on what the min minimum
is right so here the minimum is the
other thing that you want to look into
now
there are many more things that we just
scratched the surface guys i mean i you
know
super
uh
happy i'm happy that you know that we
did all this stuff oh look at me it's my
face and my face
um kind of happy that we did all this
stuff i mean it's a lot
uh to go through
um i didn't change much but
you know i probably won't
push my changes i don't think i
change
anything really important uh let's see
or should i
i'm just gonna do it in case i'm gonna
push all the changes i made this run and
um
and you know feel free to pull the new
information and get up to speed um
um i think this should get you started
should get you going when you finish
this you're going to see that your agent
learns to play 1v1
and in this case it's 1v scripted it's
not really the one on the other side but
you know as a one up
learns to defeat that other player
um
i encourage you you know try to continue
exploring that path i think uh what i'm
providing here should uh give you that
you know that bump bootstrap you and get
you somewhere
again final hook um
cracking deep reinforcement learning the
book is going to be available on amazon
um
november the 10th
um
it is already available in manning so
you you know feel free to go there and
there's going to be a discount somewhere
i i hope that they
uh they actually put their the discount
somewhere
uh if they haven't
then
i'm sure
i'm sure it will show up at one time or
send me send me a tweet
uh uh
tag me on a twitter tweet message and i
try to get a discount code for you
uh but i highly recommend it the you
know
the real copy is is again just available
other than that um again my tweeter
yeah just follow me on twitter
um
m-i-m-o-r-a-l-e-a
i'll be releasing uh more content uh in
the upcoming weeks um
uh and you know if you have any
questions uh just feel free to you know
reach out
i think
yes
okay that's the link that's probably one
final thing that i probably yeah let me
do that actually because
that's this is actually what motivated
me to uh do this
uh this environment
thanks for sharing so i want to share my
screen then again to
just go over that real quick
all right so
this is the
uh competition that is currently going
right so it says 24 days to go 17 days
until merger daily whatever that is
6 000 bucks price money i mean really
cool stuff right
uh
and then it's kind of sponsored i guess
by manchester city so go ahead and check
that out now this this is a serious i i
did a 1v1 you need to submit five agents
to the competition now i did all the way
to 5v5 so you know
think about it uh it's there um i just i
give you a little bootstrap right so
just go ahead and do it i probably won't
compete but
but if you have any questions let me
know
yeah look at that so
really really interesting you've got
some money in there that uh should
definitely be of interest
uh so again my twitter
uh again is
this guy over here
that over there
and then uh very very soon my youtube
channel i guess his uh channel agent
whisper or something i don't know
i i need to get
up to speed with that agent
did i get it no
okay i'll tweet it on twitter very very
soon we're gonna i'm gonna have uh i'll
start posting a bunch of videos and i
think uh
it's uh
um
it would be nice that you guys
um
you know follow along i think it's gonna
be fun oh let me see uh there all right
so do you have a discord channel i do
not
i actually joined the
they have a discord server that is
reinforcement learning i joined that
recently and i'm there uh there's a lot
of good stuff going on over there i
highly recommend that
send me a tweet if you want if you want
the link i i'm honestly and i'm sorry
i'm not a pro on discord i
i only found out uh kind of recently i
guess
not too long ago a couple years back
but i haven't used that much and then
recently i found this uh reinforcement
learning i guess they call it server
that has a bunch of channels right and
uh
you know i'm hanging out in there so
if that's uh what you're asking i hang
out in there uh often and will you post
this video on your youtube channel
i think i'm gonna leave this video here
i'll probably ask madden if they let me
uh
you know cross post but i know that dave
manning actually posts this anyway so
um i think i'm gonna start posting new
stuff on my youtube channel and more
condensed obviously we'll do one two
hours at one point but for the most part
it's gonna be ten minute videos like i'm
going to explain to you just a very
specific algorithm and you know a very
specific problem and so i don't want to
uh you know
i don't want you guys to have to deal
with my
my moments of thinking right
how do i say this i rather you guys to
get the information straight uh when you
want it and sometimes this format is
also
good
but uh yeah that's it
i hope you like it guys and yeah support
the book
you know twitter i'll tweet my my
youtube channel soon and then i'll stop
i'll start posting and i hope you uh
get involved all right
thank you all thank you so much